ha sido una noche bastante dura para la
mayoría de los ucranianos aquí lleno de
esa regresó la luz relativamente
temprano a las 9 de la noche en ciertas
partes de la ciudad pero en otras
realmente Desde la madrugada ha vuelto a
irse y las y las poblacion está
obviamente no solamente pasándolo muy
mal porque tampoco tiene agua en algunos
sectores sino que que también están
previendo un invierno bastante bastante
fuerte por ejemplo hemos visto esta
mañana imágenes de gente con su
secadores o haciendo cosas en cafés o en
otros lugares donde tenían electricidad
las autoridades han dicho que están
intentando restablecer la electricidad
en el resto del país hasta esta noche
hablan de que esas tres plantas
nucleares que quedaron cortadas ayer
después de ese ataque de 70 misiles
rusos 51 de ellos fueron interceptados
para los que alcanzaron a llegar
obviamente hicieron un daño enorme como
el que vimos el resto del país Ellos
dicen que a partir de esta noche del
servicio debe estar totalmente
restablecido sino que pero también esto
empieza a crear una gran preocupación en
la población porque empiezan a
plantearse Raúl que va a pasar en el
resto de estos meses venideros cuando
Incluso el frío sea mayor